look at this you take my breath away you
really do this is a masterpiece this
dresser you got to tell me who it is and
had to tow these jewels because I'm
thinking are these in your own closet
because you always do that - they're
from your own the jewels but the dress
is ELISA the master is so amazing with
the design so beautiful we just had a
lot of your cast here and they are so
excited about tonight what does the
sustained sustained success of this film
mean to you guys and then to have your
peer say well done good job it is always
important isn't it you know to be
recognized by your peers yes yeah
because we all know how much hard work
we put it into it how much you love we
put it into it and it's nice whether
they turn around and say yes you did
you're just a success at the box office
but we recognize that is a great movie
as well so thank you every time I see
you I'm gonna have to ask about the
sequel you know that have you seen a
script where are we have you heard
anything well you know Kevin Kwan wrote
a trilogy yeah that Warner Brothers have
a trilogy so that our producers Nina
Brad and John they are working very hard
on the two scripts but things are
happening oh yes okay so you are going
to be in Star Trek Discovery our CBS all
access series how cool is that like god
it is amazing the quality of work is
phenomenal um do you remember how you
got your sag card oh gosh I got it
actually very late welcome so many years
really
well you know I think really the movie
that got me through the door was Memoirs
of a Geisha I was just in London on the
set of last Christmas with Henry and
Amelia and I know you're in it as well
so we can't wait for that coming out
this Christmas yes that's right so
you'll be seeing me with Henry again
but I love working with Paul Feig Emma
Thompson my god she's like my hero
[Music]